kitty can we workshop conan's obituary
yeah i mean i am curious because i want
to know am i going to get a new york
times obituary because i think it's all
when you go meaning of i think if i'm in
a ballooning accident tomorrow yeah i'm
getting a new york times obituary that's
pretty awesome gee i hope i go in a
balloon tomorrow
but
but
but see i'm not worried about that
because i'm not going to go ballooning
tomorrow okay safe that's good
but if i stick around too long
um and i go on like 92
i'm not gonna get anything because if
you stick to if you stick around too
long past your prime they don't care
anymore oh yeah i'll get a shout out in
the brookline chronicle but that's gonna
be about it so what do i do how do i
make sure i don't lose my slot in new
york times open
you
keep going
doing what you're doing and you won't be
washed up by 92 you'll still be out
there
you know well kitty i know that they
write like certain celebrities obits in
advance when they're uh in advanced age
how early do they start doing that yeah
has someone already written mine
somewhere oh god yes yep
have you kitty yeah not me there's a
file at the new york times that they
you know that's how come when someone
dies their obituary pops up so fast
because it's already mostly written yeah
but i think they do that they don't do
that for for
young vibrant like the moment conan got
a talk show they started writing that
over exactly i've got to read it i've
got to say i know because they'll write
whatever they want about it
yeah
yeah you can't see it they'll never show
it to you no you should write you should
call them right now you should call the
obituary desk here's what i want i want
um i want the phrase sexual athlete to
be in there i want them to say conan was
a sexual athlete and had an animal
magnetism
i don't care if it's true or not i just
want it in there that's going to be when
conan the barbarian dies
[Laughter]
we need to get the locksmith from last
week's episode get him to break us into
the new york times
right and bring the roller skating woman
from another episode to take out the
guards by smashing into them you know
what we should do we can use
all of the people i've interviewed uh in
these conan o'brien fan segments i can
talk to them and i can reunite them and
we could form this super team yeah this
is the heist crew look there's a
locksmith oh brian's eleven yeah
and then the whole goal
is to break into the new york times find
my obit and then i use you kitty you
have to come with us through the whole
thing everyone else is taking out guards
picking locks creating a special kind of
chloroform that knocks people out and
then you're the one finally when we get
in and we've hacked the system with one
of the i.t people i've talked to
then you write the obit that i want
conan o'brien known for his animal
magnetism and his sexual athleticism is
gone and 144. i've got it hold on
wait she's right crew's going to be dead
your crew's going to be logged in
i don't have to get tattoos from that
that woman yes what's the tattoo right
all right conan's 11. yeah it should be
a cartoon show like scooby-doo i like it
okay all right well we've created a
really good show or maybe it's just a
whole other spin-off podcast called
conan writes his own bid
and pages